الله اكبر الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله حي على الصلاه
حي على
الفلاح قد قامت
الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر
لا اله الا
الله استووا
واعتدلوا ساووا الصفوف سدوا الفرج
استو الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
قل الحمد لله وسلام على عباده الذين اصطفى
ا الله خير اما
يشركون امن خلق السماوات والارض وانزل لكم
من
السماء ماء
فانبتنا به فانبتنا به
حدائق ذات بهجه ما كان لكم ان تنبتوا
شجرها االه مع
الله بل هم قوم
يعدلون امن جعل الارض قرارا وجعل خلالها
انهارا وجعل لها رواسي وجعل بين البحرين
حاجزا
االه مع
الله بل اكثرهم لا
يعلمون
امن يجيب المضطر اذا دعاه ويكشفوا السوء
ويجعلكم
خلفاء الارض
اههم مع الله قليلا ما تذكرون
امن يهديكم في ظلمات البر والبحر ومن يرسل
الرياح بشرا بين يدي
رحمته
االه مع الله
االه مع الله سبحانه وتعالى عما
يشركون
ام تعالى الله عما
امن يبدا الخلق ثم يعيده ومن يرزقكم من
السماء
والارض
االه مع
الله قل هاتوا برهانكم ان كنتم
صادقين قل لا يعلم من في السماوات والارض
الغيب الا
الله وما يشعرون ايان
يبعثون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
قل لا يعلم من في السماوات والارض الغيب
الا
الله وما يشعرون ايان
يبعثون بل ادارك علمهم في الاخره بل هم في
شك منها بل هم منها
عمون وقال الذين كفروا ائذا كنا ترابا
واباؤنا اانا
لمخرجون لقد وعدنا هذا نحن
واباؤنا من قبل ان هذا الا اساطير
الاولين قل سيروا في الارض
فانظروا كيف كان عاقبه
المجرمين ولا تحزن عليهم ولا ولا تكن في
ضيق مما
يمكرون ويقولون متى هذا الوعد ان كنتم
صادقين قل عسى ان يكون ردف لكم بعض الذي
تستعجلون وان ربك لذو فضل على الناس ولكن
اكثرهم لا
يشكرون وان ربك ليعلم ما تكن صدورهم وما
يعلنون وما من
غائبه في
السماء والارض الا في كتاب
مبين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الله سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
اكبر الله
[Silence]
الله سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
استهوا استهوا اعتدلوا
الله
اكبر
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ان هذا القران يقص على بني
اسرائيل اكثر الذي هم فيه يختلفون
وانه لهدى ورحمه
للمؤمنين ان ربك يقضي بينهم بحكمه وهو
العزيز العليم فتوكل على
الله انك على الحق المبين انك لا تسمع
الموتى ولا تسمع الصم
الدعاء اذا ولوا
مدبرين وما انت بهادي العمي عن
ضلالتهم ان تسمع الا من يؤمن باياتنا فهم
مسلمون واذا وقع القول عليهم اخرجنا لهم
دابه من الارض تكلمهم ان الناس كانوا
باياتنا لا
يوقنون ويوم نحشر من كل امه فوجا ممن يكذب
باياتنا فهم
يوزعون حتى اذا
جاءوا قال اكذبتم
باياتي ولم تحيطوا بهاها علما
اماذا كنتم
تعملون ووقع القول عليهم بما ظلموا فهم لا
ينطقون الم الم يروا انا جعلنا الليل
ليسكنوا فيه
والنهار مبصرا ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يؤمنون ويوم ينفخ في الصور ففزع من في
السماوات ومن في الارض الا من شاء
الله وكل اتوه
داخرين وترى الجبال تحسبها
جامده وهي تمر مر
السحاب صنع الله الذي اتقن كل شيء انه
خبير بما
تفعلون من جاء بالحسنه فله خير منها وهم
من فزع يومئذ
امنون ومن جاء بالسيئه فكبت وجوههم في
النار هل تجزون الا ما كنتم
تعملون انما امرت ان اعبد رب هذه البلده
الذي حرمها وله كل
شيء وامرت ان اكون من
المسلمين وان اتلو
القران فمن اهتدى فانما يهتدي لنفسه ومن
ضل فقل انما انا من
المنذرين وقل الحمد لله سيريكم اياته
فتعرفونها وما ربك بغافل
عما
تعملون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين طا
س
م تلك ايات الكتاب المبين نتلو عليك من
نبا موسى وفرعون بالحق لقوم
يؤمنون ان فرعون على في الارض وجعل اهلها
شيعا يستضعف
طائفه منهم يذبح
ابناءهم ويستحيي
نساءهم انه كان من
المفسدين ونريد ان نمن على الذين استضعفوا
في الارض ونجعلهم ائ ونجعلهم
الوارثين ونمكن لهم في الارض ونري فرعون
وهامان وجنودهما منهم ما كانوا
يحذرون واوحينا الى ام موسى ان
ارضعيه فاذا خفت عليه فالقيه في اليم ولا
تخافي ولا ت احزني انا
رادوه اليك وجاعلوه من
المرسلين
فالتقطه ال فرعون ليكون لهم عدوا وحزنا ان
فرعون وهامان وجنودهما كانوا
خاطئين وقالت امراه فرعون قره عين لي ولك
لا تقتلوه عسى ان ين فعنا او نتخذه ولدا
وهم لا
يشعرون واصبح فؤاد ام موسى فارغا ان كادت
لتبدي به لولا ان ربطنا على قلبها لتكون
من
المؤمنين وقالت لاخته قصيه فبصرت به عن
جنب وهم لا
يشعرون وحرمنا عليه المراضع من قبل فقالت
هل ادلكم على اهل بيت يكفلونه لكم وهم له
ناصحون فرددناه الى امه كي تقر عينها ولا
تحزن ولتعلم ان وعد الله حق ولكن اكثرهم
لا
يعلمون ولما بلغ اشد ده واستوى اتيناه
حكما وعلما وكذلك نجزي
المحسنين ودخل المدينه على حين غفله من
اهلها فوجد فيها رجلين
يقتتلان هذا من شيعته وهذا من عدوه
فاستغاثه الذي من شيعته على الذي من عدوه
فوكزه موسى فق
عليه قال هذا من عمل الشيطان انه عدو مضل
مبين قال رب اني ظلمت نفسي فاغفر لي فغفر
له انه هو الغفور
الرحيم قال رب بما انعمت علي فلن اكون
ظهيرا
للمجرمين فاصبح في المدينه
خائفا
يترقب فاذا الذي استنصره بالامس
يستصرخه قال له موسى انك لغوي
مبين فلما ان اراد ان يبطش بالذي هو عدو
لهما قال يا موسى اتريد ان
تقتلني قال يا موسى اتريد ان ان تقتلني
كما قتلت نفسا
بالامس ان تريد الا ان تكون جبارا في
الارض وما تريد ان تكون من
المصلحين وجاء رجل من اقصى المدينه يسعى
قال يا موسى ان الملا ياتمرون بك ليقتلوك
فاخرج اني لك من الناصحين
فخرج منها
خائفا يترقب قال رب نجني من القوم
الظالمين ولما توجه ت القاء مدين قال عسى
ربي قال عسى ربي ان يهديني
سواء
السبيل الله
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر
السلام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحم
ال الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين ولما توجهت القاء مدين قال عسى ربي
ان يهديني سواء
السبيل ولما ورد ماء مدين وجد عليه امه من
الناس يسقون ووجد من دونهم امراتين
تذودان قال ما خطبكما قال تلا نسقي حتى
يصدر الرعاء وابونا شيخ
كبير فسقى لهما ثم تولى الى الظل فقال رب
اني لما انزلت الي من خير
فقير فجاءته
احداهما تمشي على
استحياء قالت قالت ان ابي يدعوك ليجزيك
اجر ما سقيت لنا فلما
جاءه وقص عليه القصص قال لا تخف نجوت من
القوم
الظالمين قالت احداهما يا ابت استاجره ان
خير من استاجرت القوي الامين قال قال اني
اريد ان انكحك احدى ابنتي هاتين على ان
تاجرني ثماني حجج فان اتممت عشرا فمن عندك
وما اريد ان اشق
عليك ستجدني ان شاء الله من
الصالحين قال ذلك بيني وبينك ايما الاجلين
قضيت فلا عدوان علي والله على ما نقول
وكيل فلما قضى موسى الاجل وسار باهله انس
من جانب الطور نارا قال لاهلهم
كثواب نارا لعلي اتيكم منها بخبر او جذوه
من النار لعلكم
تصطلون فلما اتى نودي من شاطئ الوادي
الايمن في البقعه المباركه من الشجره اي
يا موسى ان يا موسى اني انا الله رب
العالمين وان الق
عصاك فلما راها تهتز كانها
ج ولا مدبرا ولم يعقب
يا موسى اقبل ولا تخف انك من
الامنين اسلك يدك في جيبك تخرج بيضاء من
غير سوء واضمم اليك جناحك من الرهب فذلك
برهانان من ربك الى فرعون وملاه انهم
كانوا قوما
فاسقين قال رب اني قتلت منهم نفسا فاخاف
ان
يقتلون واخي هارون هو افصح من مني لسانا
فارسله مع يرد ان
يصدقني اني اخاف ان
يكذبون قال سنشد عضدك باخيك ونجعل لكما
سلطانا فلا يصلون
اليكما باياتنا انتما ومن اتبع معكم
الغالبون فلما
جاءهم موسى باياتنا بينات قالوا ما هذا
الا سحر مفتر وما
سمعنا وما سمعنا بهذا في
ابائنا
الاولين وقال موسى ربي اعلم بمن جاء
بالهدى من عنده ومن تكون له عاقبه
الدار انه لا يفلح
الظالمون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
[Silence]
وقال موسى ربي اعلم من جاء بالهدى من عنده
ومن تكون له عاقبه
الدار انه لا يفلح
الظالمون وقال فرعون يا ايها الملا ما
علمت لكم من اله غيري فاوقد لي يا هامان
على الطين فاجعل لي صرحا لعلي اطلع الى
اله موسى واني لاظنه من
الكاذبين واستكبر هو وجنوده في الارض بغير
الحق وظنوا انهم الينا لا
يرجعون فاخذناه وجنود
فنبذناهم في اليم فانظر كيف كان عاقبه
الظالمين وجعلناهم ائمه يدعون الى النار
ويوم القيامه لا
ينصرون
واتبعناهم في هذه الدنيا لعنه ويوم
القيامه هم من المقبوحين
ولقد اتي موسى الكتاب من بعد ما اهلكنا
القرون الاولى بصائر للناس وهدى ورحمه
وهدى ورحمه لعلهم
يتذكرون وما كنت بجانب الغربي اذ قضينا
الى موسى الامر وما كنت من
الشاهدين ولا لكنا انشانا قرونا فتطاول
عليهم العمر وما كنت ثاويا في اهل مدين
تتلوا عليهم اياتنا ولكنا كنا
مرسلين وما كنت بجانب الطور اذ نادينا
ولكن رحمه من
ربك ولكن رحمه من ربك لتنذر قوما ما اهم
من نذير من قبلك لعلهم
يتذكرون ولولا ان تصيبهم مصيبه بما قدمت
ايديهم
فيقولوا فيقولوا ربنا لولا ارسلت الينا
رسولا فنتبع اياتك ونكون من
المؤمنين فلما
جاءهم الحق من عندنا ق قالوا لولا اوتي
مثل ما اوتي موسى اولم يكفروا بما اوتي
موسى من قبل قالوا سحران تظاهرا وقالوا
انا بكل
كافرون قل فاتوا بكتاب من عند الله هو
اهدى منه ما اتبعه ان كنتم
صادقين فان لم يستجيب لك فاعلم فان لم
يستجيبوا لك فاعلم انما يتبعون
اهواهم ومن اضل ممن اتبع هواه بغير هدى من
الله ان الله لا يهدي القوم
الظالمين الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
ا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على رسول الله وعلى اله وصحبه ومنوه ومن
تبع باحسان ال يوم الدين ا
بعد سبحان الله
عه موى عليه الهلام الله سبحانه
وتالى as
م عليه الصلا
والسلام مى عليهه
واللام think he the real person in that
he
the still fromer
م عليه
[Silence]
عليه person happens to die from the slap
i mean if we think about it nobody dies
from a slap face but it happens to be he
and
of says is from you know he has done
this so but the fact the matter is the
person is at time and now the people are
gathering up so he runs away and tries
to
‏youer are
desig is things
are عليه
[Silence]
عليه
there
once are
water who
‏fe two wom cor wai fl
why father cann do here what
over علق
[Silence]
فقال رب اني لما انزلت الي منير
‏come
[Silence]
‏when he invited to the house of the
father to marry one of daughters him he
gives them flock of sheep and he says
can gra for for age
upon all
‏youy come here
come so man number one got roof
over got some food right he got a job
as you know to care of the fl and then
he
also ‏so this is a very complete and way
just
because
mared
isover الله
سال
because
accept because the following
things in
nexts the de is done right take
home and their father is also
‏and from the blessing at
bl قران
you even though you not sent to people
ofan you
also my words qur says is the
tell you come
up came
‏right so when
are
are تشهد رب اني لما انزلت اليه من خير
فقير
والعا لا اله الا انت سبحانك اني كنت من
الظالمين
ح شاء
الله الله
الله اللهبه
[Silence]
اللهى سبان و نقص عليكم احن
الصول الله صل علسر
‏first
[Silence]
‏and
remember it's only matter of
time الله سبحانه وتالى
is الله سبحان وتالى a person is
against transgressing allah lets that to
go fur and fur and f to see how much of
bigger can themselves
[Silence]
الله wasc
‏be aware things and not for
them sisters
chers the sisters
ssing how tre and how
being s we
about how state of
[Silence]
‏fin عش اللهبه وتال
‏all wat
الله
سبحت ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره
حسنه وقنا عذاب النار وقنا عذاب القبر
وقنا عذاب جنم وقنا شر فتنه المحيا والمات
وكنا شرف مسيح الدجال ربنا تقبل منك
السميع العليم وتوب علينا يا م تواب
الرحيم وصلى الله على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين برحمك الرامين اللهم امين اللهم
امين اللهم
فجر صلاه
5ج استقيم اعتدل
استو
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولقد وصلنا لهم القول لعلهم
يتذكرون الذين اتيناهم الكتاب من قبله هم
به
يؤمنون واذا يتلى عليهم قالوا امنا به ان
انه الحق من
ربنا
انا كنا من قبله
مسلمين اولئك يؤتون اجرهم مرتين بما صبروا
ويدرؤون
بالحسنه السيئه
ومما
رزقناهم
ينفقون واذا سمعوا اللغو اعرض عنه وقالوا
لنا اعمالنا ولكم
اعمالكم سلام عليكم لا نبتغي
الجاهلين
انك لا تهدي من احببت ولكن الله يهدي من
يشاء وهو اعلم بالمهتدين
وقالوا ان اتبع الهدى معك نتخطف من
ارضنا اولم نمكن لهم حرما امنا يجبى اليه
ثمرات كل شيء
رزقا يجبى اليه ثمرات كل شيء رزقا من
لدنا ولكن اكثرهم لا
يعلمون وكم اهلكنا من قريه
بطرت
معيشتها فتلك مساكنهم لم تسكن من بعدهم
الا
قليلا
وكنا نحن
الوارثين وما كان ربك مهلك القرى حتى يبعث
في امها رسولا يتلوا عليهم
اياتنا وما كن مهلك القرى الا واهلها
ظالمون وما اوتيتم من شيء فمتاع الحياه
الدنيا
وزينتها وما عند الله خير وابقى افلا
تعقلون افمن وعدناه وعدا حسنا فهو لاقيه
كمن
متعناه كمن متعناه متاع الحياه
الدنيا
ث هو يوم القيامه من
المحضرين ويوم يناديهم فيقول اين
شركائي الذين كنتم
تزعمون قال الذين حق عليهم القول ربنا
هؤلاء الذين اغوينا اغويناهم كما
غوينا تبرانا اليك ما كانوا ايانا
يعبدون وقيل ادعوا
شركاءكم فدعوهم فلم يستجيبوا لهم وراوا
العذاب لو انهم كانوا
يهتدون ويوم ناديهم فيقول ماذا اجبتم
المرسلين فعميت عليهم
الانباء يومئذ فهم لا
يتساءلون فاما من تاب وامن وعمل صالحا
فعسى فعسى ان يكون من المفلحين
وربك يخلق ما يشاء
ويختار ما كان لهم
الخيره سبحان الله وتعالى عما
يشركون وربك يعلم ما تكن صدورهم وما
يعلنون وهو الله لا اله الا هو له الحمد
في الاولى والاخره
وله الحكم واليه
ترجعون قل ارايتم ان جعل الله عليكم الليل
سرمدا الى يوم
القيامه من اله غير الله ياتيكم
بضياء افلا
تسمعون قل ارايتم ان جعل الله عليكم
النهار سرمدا الى يوم
القيامه من اله غير الله
ياتيكم بليل تسكنون فيه افلا
تبصرون ومن رحمته جعل لكم الليل
والنهار لتسكنوا فيه ولتبتغوا من فضله
ولعلكم تشكرون
ويوم يناديهم فيقول اين
شركائي الذين كنتم
تزعمون ونزعنا من كل
امه شهيدا
فقلنا فقلنا هاتوا برهانكم فعلموا ان الحق
لله وضل
عنهم ما كانوا
يفترون الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ان
كان من قوم موسى فبغى عليهم
واتيناه
واتيناه من الكنوز ما ان مفاتحه لتنوء
بالعصبه اولي
القوه اذ قال له قومه لا تفرح ان الله لا
يحب
الفرحين وابتغ فيما اتاك الله ال الاخره
ولا تنسى نصيبك من
الدنيا
واحسن كما احسن الله
اليك ولا تبغي الفساد في الارض ان الله لا
يحب
المفسدين قال انما اوتيته على علم
عندي اولم يعلم ان الله قد اهلك من من
قبله من القرون من هو اشد منه قوه من هو
اشد منه قوه واكثر
جمعا ولا يسال عن ذنوبهم
المجرمون فخرج على قومه في زينته قال
الذين يريدون الحياه الدنيا يا ليت لنا
مثل ما اوتي
قارون انه لذو حظ
عظيم وقال الذين اوتوا العلم ويلكم ثواب
الله خير لمن امن وعمل
صالحا ولا يلقاها الا
الصابرون فخسفنا به وبداره
الارض فما كان له من فئه ينصرونه من دون
الله وما كان من
المنتصرين واصبح الذين تمنوا مكانه بالامس
يقولون يقولون ويك ان الله يبسط الرزق لمن
يشاء من عباده
ويقدر لولا ان من الله علينا لخسف
بنا وي
كانه لا يفلح
الكافرون تلك الدار الاخره نجعلها للذين
لا يريدون علوا في الارض ولا
فسادا
والعاقبه
للمتقين من جاء بالحسنه فله خير
منها من جاء بالسيئه فلا يجزى الذين عملوا
السيئات الا ما كانوا
يعملون ان الذي فرض عليك القران
لرادك الى
معاد قل ربي اعلم من جاء بالهدى ومن هو في
ضلال مبين
وما كنت ترجو ان يلقى اليك الكتاب الا
رحمه من ربك فلا
تكونن ظهيرا
للكافرين ولا يصد ولا
يصدنك عن ايات الله بعد اذ انزلت
اليك وادع الى ربك ولا تكونن
من
المشركين ولا تدع مع الله الها
اخر لا اله الا هو كل شيء هالك الا
وجهه له الحكم واليه
ترجعون الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
استقيم واعتدلو
الله
اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
الم
م احسب الناس ان يتركوا ان يقولوا امنا
وهم لا يفتنون
ولقد فتنا الذين من قبلهم
فليعلمن الله الذين صدقوا
وليعلمن
الكاذبين ام حسب الذين يعملون السيئات ان
يسبقونا
ساء ما
يحكمون من كان يرجو لقاء الله فان اج الله
لات وهو السميع
العليم ومن جاهد فانما يجاهد لنفسه ان
الله لغني عن
العالمين والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
لنكفرن عنهم
سيئاتهم
ولنجزينهم احسن الذي كانوا يعملون
ووصينا الانسان بوالديه حسنا وان جاهداك
لتشرك بيما ليس لك به علم فلا
تطعهما الي مرجعكم
فبكم بما كنتم
تعملون والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
لندخلنهم في
الصالحين ومن من الناس من يقول امنا
بالله فاذا اوذي في الله جعل فتنه
الناس فاذا اوذي في الله جعل فتنه الناس
كعذاب
الله ولئن جاء نصر من ربك
ليقولن انا كنا معكم اوليس الله باعلم بما
في صدور
العالمين
وليعلمن الله الذين امنوا اوليس الله
باعلم بما في
صدور
عالمين
وليعلمن الله الذين امنوا
وليعلمن
المنافقين وقال الذين كفروا للذين امنوا
نتبع سبيلنا ولنحمل
خطاياكم وما هم بحاملين من
خطاياهم من شيء
انهم
لكاذبون
وليحملن اثقالهم
واثقالا مع
اثقالهم
وليسن يوم القيامه عما كانوا
يفترون ولقد ارسلنا نوحا الى قومه فلبث
فيهم فلبث فيهم الف سنه الا خس عاما
فاخذهم الطوفان وهم
ظالمون
فانجيناه واصحاب السفينه وجعلناها ايه
للعالمين وابراهيم اذ قال لقومه اعبدوا
الله واتقوا
ذلكم خير لكم ان كنتم
تعلمون انما تعبدون من دون الله اوثانا
وتخلقون وتخلقون افكا ان الذين تعبدون من
دون الله لا
يملكون ان الذين تعبدون من دون الله لا
يملكون لكم رزقا فابتغوا عند الله الرزق
واعبدوه واشكروا له اليه ترجعون وان
تكذبوا فقد كذب امم من
قبلكم وما على الرسول الا البلاغ المبين
اولم يروا كيف يبدئ الله الخلق ثم يعيده
ان في ذ ان ذلك على الله يسير قل سيروا في
الارض فانظروا كيف بدا الخلق ثم الله ينشئ
النشاه
الاخره ان الله على كل شيء قدير يعذب من
يشاء ويرحم من يشاء
واليه
تقلبون وما انتم بمعجزين في الارض ولا في
السماء وما لكم من دون الله من ولي ولا
نصير والذين كفروا بايات الله
ولقائه اولئك ياسوا من
رحمتي ا اك يئسوا من رحمتي واولئك لهم
عذاب
اليم فما كان جواب قومه الا ان قالوا
اقتلوه او
حرقوه او
حرقوه فانجا الله من النار
ان في ذلك لايات لقوم يؤمنون
وقال انما اتخذتم من دون الله اوثانا موده
بينكم موده بينكم في الحياه
الدنيا ثم يوم القيامه يكفر بعضكم ببعض
ويلعن بعضكم
بعضا وماواهم النار وما لكم من ناصرين
فامن له
لوط وقال اني مهاجر الى ربي انه هو العزيز
الحكيم ووهبنا له اسحاق ويعقوب واجعلنا في
ذريته النبوه
والكتاب
واتيناه اجره في
الدنيا وان انه في الاخره لمن
الصالحين الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
بسم الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولوطا اذ قال لقومه انكم لت
الفاحشه انكم لتاتون الفاحشه ما سبقكم بها
من احد من
العالمين ا انكم لتاتون الرجال وتقطعون
السبيل وتاتون في ناديكم
المنكر فما كان جواب قومه الا ان قالوا
ائتنا بعذاب
الله الا ان قالوا ائتنا بعذاب الله ان
كنت من
الصادقين قال رب انصرني على القوم
المفسدين ولما
جاءت رسلنا ابراهيم بالبشرى قالوا انا
مهلكوا اهل هذه
القريه ان اهلها كانوا ان اهلها كانوا
ظالمين قال ان فيها لوطا قالوا نحن اعلم
بمن فيها
لنن واهله الا امراته كانت من
الغابرين ولما ان
جاءت رسلنا لوطا سيء بهم سي
بهم وضاق بهم ذرعا وقالوا لا تخف ولا تحزن
انا منجوك واهلك الا امراتك كانت من
الغابرين انا منزلون على اهل هذه القريه
رجزا من السماء بما كانوا
يفسدون بما كانوا يفسد يفسق بما كانوا
يفسق بما كانوا
يفسقون ولقد تركنا منها ايه بينه لقوم
يعقلون والى مدين اخاهم شعيبا فقال يا قوم
اعبدوا الله وارجوا اليوم الاخر ولا تعثوا
في الارض
مفسدين فكذبوه فاخذته
الرجفه فاصبحوا في دارهم جاثمين وعادا
وثمود وقد تبين لكم من
مساكنهم وزين لهم الشيطان اعمالهم فصدهم
عن السبيل وما كانوا
مستبصرين وقارون وفرعون
وهامان ولقد جاءهم
موسى بالبينات فاستكبروا
فاستكبروا في الارض وما كانوا
سابقين فكلا اخذنا
بذنبه فمنهم من ارسلنا عليه
حاصبا ومنهم من اخذته الصيحه ومنهم من
خسفنا به الارض ومنهم من
اغرقنا وما كان الله ليظلمهم ولكن كانوا
انفسهم
يظلمون مثل الذين اتخذوا من دون الله
اولياء كمثل العنكبوت اتخذت بيتا وان اوهن
البيوت لبيت العنكبوت لو كانوا
يعلمون ان الله يعلم ما يدعون من د
من شيء وهو العزيز
الحكيم وتلك الامثال نضربها للناس وما
يعقلها الا
العالمون خلق الله السماوات والارض بالحق
ان في ذلك لايه
للمؤمنين اتل ما اوحي اليك من الكتاب واقم
صلاه ان الصلاه تنهى عن
الفحشاء
والمنكر ولذكر الله اكبر والله يعلم ما
تصنعون الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
استقيم اعتدل
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى
والذي قدر فهدى والذي اخرج المرعى فجعله
غثاء
احوى سنقرئك فلا تنسى الا ما شاء
الله انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسمه ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا والاخره خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله
اكبر سمع الله
لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالم امين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل يا ايها
الكافرون لا اعبد ما
تعبدون ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد
ولا انا عابد ما
عبدتم ولا انتم عابدون ما
اعبد لكم دينكم
وليدين الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده اللهم تم نورك فهديت فلك الحمد عظم
حلمك فعفوت فلك الحمد بسطت يدك فاعطيت فلك
الحمد فلك الحمد يا ربنا مل السماء والارض
ومل ما بينهما ومل ما شئت من شيء
بعد اللهم يا ربنا ويا مولانا ويا س ويا
سيدنا ويا الهنا يا من تسمع كلامنا وترى
مك نا وتعلم سرنا
وعلانيتنا يا من لا يخفى عليك شيء من
امرنا نستغفرك ربنا من جميع الذنوب
والخطايا ونتوب
اليك اللهم اهدنا في من هديت وعافنا في من
عافيت وتولنا في من توليت وبارك لنا فيما
اعطيت واصرف عنا برحمتك شر ما قدرت وقضيت
انك تقضي بالحق ولا يقضى عليك انه لا يذل
من واليت ولا يعز من عاديت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت نستغفرك ربنا من جميع الذنوب
والخطايا ونتوب اليك اللهم لا تدع لنا
ذنبا الا غفرته ولا مريضا الا شفيته ولا
مبتلا الا عافيته ولا ضالا الا هديته ولا
دينا الا قضيته ولا ميتا من اموات
المسلمين الا برحمتك
رحمته اللهم كما بلغتنا رمضان
واعتناق فبلغنا ليله القدر بفضلك وكرمك
وجودك يا اكرم الاكرمين اللهم بلغنا ليله
القدر واجعلنا فيها من المعتوقين واجعلنا
فيها من المقبولين واجعلنا فيها من
الفائزين برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم
كل للمستضعفين من المسلمين في كل مكان
اللهم كل لاخواننا المستضعفين في غزه
اللهم عليك باليهود المحتلين فانهم لا
يعجزونك
اللهم عليك باليهود الظالمين فانهم لا
يعجزونك اللهم عليك باليهود الغاشمين
فانهم لا يعجزونك اللهم بعليك بقتله
النساء
والاطفال اللهم احصهم عددا واقتلهم بددا
ولا تغادر منهم احدا اللهم في هذا الشهر
الفضيل بلغ اخواننا في غزه وعجل لهم بنصرك
وعجل لهم بنصرك ومددا من عندك برحمتك يا
ارحم
الراحمين ربنا تقبل منا انك انت السميع
العليم وتب علينا يا مولانا انك انت
التواب الرحيم اللهم تجاوز عنا السيئات
وتحمل عنا
التبعات برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم صل
وسلم وبارك على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه
والتابعين اللهم وارضى عنا وعنهم
اجمعين سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون
وسلام على المرسلين والحمد لله رب
العالمين الله اكبر
الله
اكب الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏s